[Aplausos]
bueno
está comprobado que podemos llegar a
tener hasta 70 mil pensamientos por día
70 mil cifra que la verdad desconocía
hasta el momento de preparar esta charla
y tan sólo uno de esos pensamientos
puede llegar a hacer eso que llamamos
idea
se me ocurre el hombre el hombre que
mostrar pensante que tiene la capacidad
de poder estar creando y de ando
buscando soluciones a problemas todo el
tiempo
pensemos en el hombre primitivo y
dejando la forma de cómo hacer fuego
para calentarse para cocinar para
defenderse y también creando la rueda
para poder agilizar cosas rápidamente
pero
preguntemos esto empezamos así que es
una idea de qué hablamos cuando hablamos
de idea es una abstracción un
pensamiento complejo es intangible que
surge en nuestra mente en la vida
cotidiana tenemos las ideas generales
las comunes como por ejemplo le tengo
que comprar la casa al perro o acá hace
falta una luz o tv poner una papelera de
eso que llamamos la idea
esa idea que me hace sentir único que
digo con esta la pego que a nadie más se
le ocurrió
que soy el elegido el iluminado
pero qué es lo primero que se nos viene
a la cabeza esa idea será solamente mía
solo yo tuve esa idea capaz que no se le
ocurrió a ella oa él o alguien allá
arriba entonces frente a esa
incertidumbre que hacemos que es lo que
tendemos a hacer quiero ir a una oficina
del gobierno o un organismo a registrar
mi idea quiero ir a una ventanilla y
decirle mire señor se me ocurre esta
idea es única nadie más la puede
reproducir solo yo quiero tener esta
idea ahora bien
pensemos
no se pueden registrar las ideas las
ideas no se registran y eso es algo que
quiero que quede claro en esta charla
ted no podemos registrar las ideas
entonces hacemos frente a esa
frustración de que no podemos registrar
y que esa idea sea solamente nuestra
única
qué es lo que hacemos tenemos que pasar
por un cierto estadio ciertas etapas que
lo voy
a ubicar primero que nada tenemos que
desprendernos apartarnos de ese
enamoramiento de que la idea es única de
ese sueño idílico de que solo yo tuve
esa idea para luego centrarme en su
materialización en su ejecución en
tratar de darle forma a esa idea que
tenemos
luego
silencio tenemos que hacer silencio
silencio porque tenemos que ser los
primeros en llegar a ese lugar que
descubrimos la idea no se puede divulgar
entonces solamente tenemos que elegir
aquellas personas que sabemos que nos
van a ayudar en su materialización
muchas veces podemos tener una idea y no
usar los actos para ejecutarla
necesitamos un técnico un desarrollo un
desarrollador de software no sabemos
entonces cuidado la idea hay que
cuidarla secreto tercero
buscar ayuda y ahí es donde entramos los
especialistas cuando buscamos ayuda lo
primero que podemos hacer es si no sos
apto para esa idea y tenés que buscar la
colaboración de alguien técnico primero
quizás podemos trabajar en la
confidencialidad tienes que proteger esa
idea de a quién se la vas a exponer
segundo vamos a ir clasificando esa idea
y para clasificar la traje a esta charla
se me ocurrió un ejemplo que es el
programa the world no sé si todos lo
conocen es un panel enorme donde el
juego cuando inicia larga una bola que
va transitando por determinadas etapas
hasta que calle en un casillero
casillero que por lo general es el
premio que se lleva al participante
hagamos de cuenta que tenemos cuatro
casilleros y que el juego lanza a la
bola la bola va a ir pasando por todos
esos canales la vamos a ir filtrando
juntos vamos a ir viendo si es viable si
realmente sirve para lo que nosotros la
creamos si sobre todo es lo que pensamos
o quizás termina siendo otra idea por
ejemplo lanza la bola empieza por todo
ese canal y esta bola es una invención
una invención que fui escribiendo que
ensayo que ensayo de vuelta hasta que me
salió la compruebe técnicamente entonces
estamos frente a una patente patente que
vamos a colocar en el primer casillero
que tiene protección que una vez que él
ejecuta la puedo registrar y que hay una
ley de patentes que nos permite eso
larga otra bola el juego
es un logotipo genial lo dibujé lo
escribí pensé que podía llegar realmente
hacer eso que puede distinguir mis
servicios mi producto del resto de la
plaza comercial entonces que hice fui y
lo registre también porque existe la ley
de marcas podemos registrarlo y esto
tiene protección pero qué pasa con la
tercer bola es una creación artística es
una creación artística como una foto
como un cuadro como un guión como música
como el diseño de una web esa creación
artística también está protegida y está
protegida por el derecho de autor pero
me quiero detener unos minutos para
hablar del derecho de autor
muchas veces creemos y hay un concepto
errado de que una vez que el autor se
desprende de su obra estacional no le
pertenece esa obra se fue de su alcance
y queda a merced de quien la compró o
quien la adquirió
eso no es así es un error ya fue ese
concepto de que los derechos de autor
son el patrimonio común de la sociedad
por el simple hecho de estar en plaza
eso no es así es viejo y ya tenemos una
ley de derechos de autor pues entonces
vamos a aplicarla vamos a tenerla en la
cabeza
ustedes creativos
hace dos meses me fui con mi familia
buenos aires
me voy a registrar en el hotel llego a
la recepción y me encuentro con un
cuadro de un artista contemporáneo
argentino espectacular que llama la
atención subimos a la habitación y
cuando voy subiendo a la habitación sacó
del sobrecito la tarjetita magnética el
cuadro plateado en la tarjetita
magnética
luego voy al baño y en la cajita del
jabón el cuadro impreso en el jabón y
después voy al menú de la habitación y
el cuadro estaba ahí el cuadro por todos
lados del hotel
el dueño de ese cuadro tiene derecho a
hacer ese uso del cuadro por todos lados
por todo el merchandising del hotel el
artista pudo haber limitado el uso de
esa obra e incluso después de que se
desprendió de la misma puede obligar al
dueño a que no la use más de esa manera
y que se limite a usarla en la recepción
o puede reclamar una paga extra
otro ejemplo hace dos años tuvimos un
caso de una banda de rock uruguayo muy
conocida en nuestro país no me pregunten
el nombre porque no les va a gustar
donde hubo un concierto
auspiciado por y organizado por la
intendencia y sponsoreado por el parador
de playa
el concierto termina y a las 2 semanas
en una revista de rock
multinacional aparece la cobertura de
todo el evento las imágenes de los
artistas de su principal solista la
marca y nombre de la banda
como espónsor dando una cantidad de
toques que hubieron en la costa uruguaya
que he organizado y patrocinado también
una bebida uruguaya muy famosa ustedes
creen que el artista recibió una
consulta de que si podía usarse ese
concierto para promocionar ese evento el
artista recibió paga de eso no no
recibió nada entonces cuál es el mensaje
que nos deja el mensaje que nos deja es
que porque somos creativos tenemos la
mente abierta y nuestra obra ya fue ya
pasó el toque se hizo yo puedo hacer lo
que quiera con esa obra no entonces cree
sean creativos pero incorporen
incorporen la ley a sus creaciones es
muy importante
me queda una más
4a
la cuarta es esa idea esa idea genial
que se me ocurrió y que a nadie más se
le va a ocurrir o por lo menos eso
pienso yo que es un modelo de negocio
ese modelo de negocio que creo con esta
ya está no hay otra pero no puedo ir a
una ventanilla determinada se me ocurrió
un modelo de negocio lo quiero registrar
y no creo que nadie se entere está
varios y medio bajito para que no pase
nada y nadie se entere que en realidad
esto va a ser un boom no no puedo hacer
eso no se pueden registrar los modelos
de negocios eso es una idea que no
podemos proteger y para eso les traigo
el ejemplo de tatami tatami un grupo de
personas vienen y me consultan
tenemos idea de registrar la posibilidad
de ubicar módulos cubículos en los
lugares de trabajo para que las madres
puedan sacarse leche materna en lugares
confortables
una idea única en el mundo y se le
ocurre a gente uruguaya y yo lo que le
digo es lamentablemente no podemos
registrar esa idea lamentablemente
desconozco si en otra parte del mundo se
le está ocurriendo a otro pero entonces
que tenemos que hacer tenemos que
empezar en ese camino de la
materialización de la ejecución tenemos
que llegar primeros porque quien pega
primero pega dos veces entonces como la
vamos a proteger si no podemos
protegerla de forma directa vamos a
protegerla en forma indirecta vamos a
rodearla a esa idea vamos a registrar
una marca tatami
vamos a diseñar un sitio web
y registrar su nombre de dominio tatami
punto com.uy hagamos que los cubículos
tengan cierta forma particular para que
podamos registrarlo como diseños
ejecutemos la materialicemos esa idea
peguemos primero y eso es lo importante
cuando tenemos ese estilo de idea
entonces les quiero decir algo para
finalizar esta charla solo tenéis una
idea y las ideas no se registran así que
apúrate clasifica la materializa la
ejecuta la y pega primero porque si no
se le va a ocurrir a alguien o te la van
a robar